herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
leute ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
heute zum anfang war ganz kurz wieder
hier aus meinem aufnahme ist immer dass
wir schon ein bisschen länger nicht mehr
gesehen habt aber ich muss das head up
benutzen um euch folgendes zu zeigen und
zwar wurde super oft der wunsch geäußert
alex warum machst du nicht mehr von
wichmann bitte bisschen mehr von nicht
stellen mal wieder kostenlose produkte
bestellen mal wieder teuerste produkt
und ja also irgendwie muss ich sagen so
ruhig ist ein bisschen lärm gewöhnt da
gibt es jetzt aktuell für mich finde ich
nichts was ich unbedingt bestellen muss
es sei denn ihr habt irgendwas dann
könnte ich mir das super gerne bei
instagram schicken aber ich war dann
doch letztens mal drauf und hab
folgendes gefunden ich habe dieses
produkt her gesehen mit diesem zeichen
und das habe ich vorher noch nie
ausgesehen und ja das geht halt für
irgendwie standort wahrscheinlich so
dass es in deiner nähe ist und da bin
ich direkt drauf gegangen und dachte mir
was wisst dass eine mystery gift
platinum package box 3 mindestens drei
artikel und das krasse ist du kannst
hier so standort in deiner nähe anzeigen
dann gibst du dir deine post als hat ja
hier krispenz nails nails beautysalon
zehn kilometer weg und da waren noch 3
verfügbar muss sagen ich habe gestern
schon drei bestellt die wir jetzt gleich
abholen also heute ist montag scrollen
mal kurz runter wir sind wirklich auch
gute bewertung drin ja deswegen ich bin
so gespannt was das ist das ist einfach
das ist neu und neue sachen auch roche
muss ich natürlich testen das ganz klar
ich gehe davon aus dass sind so waren
oder auch vielleicht so restposten waren
die nicht abgeholt wurden weil diese
ganzen grauen kleinen china pakete
landen ja irgendwo und wenn die nicht
abgeholt werden als wenn die wieder
zurückgeschickt werden deswegen kann ich
mir vorstellen dass es sich um solche
warenhandel ich habe aber keine ahnung
und ich bin auch mal gespannt was für 8
euro 50 drin so leute was geht ich
befinde mich jetzt im auto wir fahren
jetzt mal hin
ich habe das hier gerade ins
navigationssystem eingegeben 13 km sind
das ab geht's los paket abholen in
nagelstudios co
so leute hier habe ich jetzt drei
wunderbaren pakete sie ja ich kann gar
nicht drauf klar das ist ja mal so
stumpf da bin ich jetzt wirklich mal auf
eure waffen in den kommentaren gespannt
weil die frau meinte sie bekommt
wirklich diese sachen aus china einfach
dahin geschickt dann kann es direkt
bestellen das habe ich also das volle
mir vorbeigegangen
das wusste ich nicht dass das jetzt geht
weil ich dachte das wäre so sachen die
da liegen geblieben während die man dann
jetzt also damit die halt nicht
wegschmeißen oder zurückschicken müssen
was weiß ich ich kann es leider nicht
aufnehmen weil ich auf meinem handy
diese qr-codes hatte aber die hatte da
so ein ganzes regal stehen voll mit
diesem kleinen paketen für was steht da
drauf bedürfnis dieses paket nicht wenn
sie nicht der empfänger sind er da steht
doch könnten empfänger drauf perfekt
regel so willkommen zurück wir haben
ganz 18 uhr paar stunden vergangen ich
bin auf jeden fall es wieder zurück
gegen gefahren weil ich das jetzt
einfach aufmachen wollte eigentlich
wollte ich das erst morgen auch machen
aber ich weiß ich bin irgendwie zu
spannend ich habe euch das schon einmal
zeigt wir haben hier einfach stumpf
pakete die wirklich einfach in diesem
laden bahn also ich verstehe dass jetzt
nicht warum aber gut das ist
wahrscheinlich so eine art zweites
standbein wie wenn dann andere laden
auch so ein dhl paket shop oder so
eröffnet oder sich für dieses
partnerprogramm an welt dass diese frau
dort in einem nagelstudio einfach diese
vision pakete verteilt er ja keine
ahnung ersten berg drauf also das war
sozusagen mein paket ich hab ja drei
pakete bestellt und die frau meinte da
sind sogar vier produkte drin in einer
tüte und nicht 3 sowie da geschrieben
also acht euro pro paket da kann man
haben sich nicht mehr kann
ich bin jetzt echt mal gespannt ich gehe
zwar davon aus dass dann im raum strömt
aber die bewertungen waren ja ganz so
schlecht
an geschaut hast du alter guck mal haben
sogar in diesem paket noch mal eins zwei
drei vier fünf sechs pakete die umwelt
wird sich freuen
das ist wirklich wirklich geisteskranken
einfach zu sechsmal plastik in einmal
plastik ich muss sagen es fühlt sich
alles so an wie kostenlose produkte
davon habe ich auch schon einige teile
gemacht jetzt machen wir einfach mal
aufgemacht nochmal hier produkte und
hier sind sage nochmal wir sind also
eher mit insgesamt 14 artikel für 24
euro
okay wir legt das einfach mal alles hier
hin und starten dann irgendwas mutet
sich mutter die adresse neben gehören
weil besteht halt wenig meine drauf so
als erstes mundschutz okay kommt man aus
china hätte ich besser nicht auch für
sollen spaß weiter geht's mit diesem
kleinen paket
ach du scheiße ja also hier haben wir
anscheinend so eine mini kette mit einer
kugel dran das sind halt wirklich alles
so sachen die man kostenlos bei
mischhaut und roma den versand bezahlen
muss und ich bin ja noch längst nicht
fertig wir haben hier
das ist da guckt euch dass man das ist
wirklich so eine lichterkette mit
fernbedienung wie kann ich jetzt schon
bei mir hinten durchs bild ziehen und
dann leuchtet also ist das testen
gemacht das ist aber wirklich auch eine
sehr lange lichterkette also von der
qualität her geht das eigentlich auch
halbwegs fit ich hatte ja auch schon
öfter mal so nähern stripes oder
irgendwie sowas
das war an sich alles kacke aber das
geht ja jetzt habe ich nicht warten ich
dachte das leuchtet komplett aber hier
leuten halt nur diese dinger ach so das
kann man doch auch machen und das dann
so verteilen
ja wundervoll und dann kannst du es halt
hier mit steuern oder auch nicht hier
fehlt jetzt auch eine knopfbatterien
scheißegal müll wirklich bis jetzt war
wirklich nur der größte müll drin aber
wir lassen ist einfach mal weiter läuft
das hier ist jetzt denke ich irgendwas
zum anziehen und kurz mal wir haben ihn
tatsächlich ein t shirt größe es war 8
durch heißen man dass sich nicht an
es ist so so was ähnliches wie ich
eigentlich an haben nur deutlich
schlechterer qualität vielleicht auch er
seinen pc hat zum schlafen aber die
qualität des grauenvollen junge ich habe
ja auch schon mal die ja ich habe ja
eigentlich alles schon mal gemacht
zumindest etwas milch produkte angeht
und auch so klammerten unboxing und das
ist halt wirklich genau diese qualität
die wir damals schon immer hatten
komplett eklig anzufassen und der vierte
block aus diesen fakten
was haben wir denn noch kann ich meine
leute ist natürlich ganz klar ich bin
hier auch mit keiner erwartungen
gegangen aber ich kann jetzt auch nicht
sagen dass ich irgendwas davon cool
finde da hätte ich die acht euro auch
anders investieren können bis jetzt
vielleicht kommt ja doch was hier haben
wir das nächste t shirt und auch etwas
das sind mit input muster oder zwar dass
sein irgendwann so was an
okay leute steht mir ganz gut ich sehe
aus wie eine kuh oder so und ja geil
55 dieses grüne paket das springen wir
schon die ganze zeit ins auge hier ist
glaube ich eben was drin zum aufblasen
ok falls es ist glaub ich schon wieder
was zum anziehen
woher alter diese qualität davon wenn
ich da so rüber wie ich kriege gänsehaut
kennt ihr das so als wenn man immer so
eine tafel ratsch das kühlt sich so
krass ich kann das gar nicht beschreiben
das ist ein handtuch alter wenn du dich
damit abwischt dann bist du auf fragen
haben finde ich bin sicher sorry dass
ich jetzt hier sofort aber es ist halt
einfach so leute bis bis jetzt kann ich
noch nichts positives über diese pakete
verlieren
aber was ist das denn
man springt ja da kannst du so ein
bisschen paar im ok das besser piepen
früher musste ich auch bei meinen eltern
auf der einfahrt oder auf der terrasse
so diese fugen weg spachteln falls man
das so nennt das schenke ich mal meinen
eltern die können das auf jeden fall
gebrauchen also liegen wir jetzt das
erste gute produkt dank weitergeht mit
ja womit das ist jetzt eine gute frage
ich weiß nicht nochmals das ist können
jeder mit irgendwas anfang also
vielleicht es sieht so aus als könnte
man das irgendwie so als kugel benutzen
verlängerte kurbel ich habe das noch nie
gesehen könnte ja gern mal in die
comments
kein plan und vielleicht obwohl ich bin
ich sicher ich habe jetzt viele
zuschauer die sich gerne so etwas
anschauen und auch gerne darauf
einstellen wenn ihr schon mal dort
pakete bestellt oder diese gitterbox
bestellter unter was dieses dritte mann
könnte das auch super gerne
implementieren das hier ist jungen ich
weiß ich weiß nicht mal was das für
sachen sind macht man weiter
hier haben wir eine super smoothie 4.0
weltklasse
ok ich weiß dass ich hier sind
wahrscheinlich jetzt so so gesunde
tabletten oder so was drin wobei ich mir
jetzt zweimal überlegen würde ob ich
solche tabletten
ach so es sind doch keine tabus das muss
man jetzt wahrscheinlich auch verpixeln
weil mein video wird sonst als nicht wer
was will ich eigentlich
wir haben ihnen nämlich ganz
offensichtlich so spielzeuge die man
sich anscheinend die warum heißt ihn
jemand mit smoothie junge kicker also
auch so
der name passt finde ich nicht so gut
wir haben wir den dann noch einmal in
also beide male in pink oder lila und
hier ist auch noch was anderes ein mini
vibrator hat so da kann man
wahrscheinlich auch der batterie wahl
tun und dann geht es ordentlich los
genau heute habe ich mich schon fast
gehabt hier kommt der batterie rein und
abfahrt
das ist wahrscheinlich jetzt wirklich so
dass das beste und wahrscheinlich auch
das teuerste was wir hatten so drei
vibratoren klar das ist jetzt keine gute
marke aber zehn und 20 euro kostet die
noch oder wie sie es eigentlich in jedem
unboxing wenn ich wieder irgendwas aus
china bestelle da sind immer so sechs
anderen länger die chinesen die sind
gleich ein bisschen bisschen horror
hier haben wir noch mal diese grünen
sachen sie steht jetzt sogar namen drauf
kitchen silikon ach so dann ist
irgendwas für die küche ich weiß nicht
wofür es genau das aber ist ja grobe
richtung also küchenutensilien
dann haben wir hier die letzten beiden
sachen einmal wieder was zum leuchten
das stinkt das alter so blätter kannst
du irgendwo anschließend und dann
leuchten alter stinken die man hier in
müssen batterien rein
und zu guter letzt haben wir dann hier
noch wahrscheinlich wieder irgendwas der
kein paar wassers ist ja ich muss sagen
im großen und ganzen wahrsten witz also
da war nichts brauchbares drin ich habe
es mir natürlich auch gedacht sind war
es ganz interessant und das wirklich so
irgendwelche geschäfte in deutschland
solche pakete liegen haben die kannst du
dann bestellen und am nächsten tag
abholen finde ich schon krass also ich
meine so billig zeug aus china zu
bestellen ist noch mal was ganz anderes
als wirklich in deutschland so was
direkt kaufen zu können finde ich
irgendwie geht das finde ich ein
bisschen in die falsche richtung
naja leute ich habe es getestet ich
hoffe es hat euch trotzdem gefallen das
sehr gerne nach oben da abonniert super
g in den kanal und wir sehen uns
wahrscheinlich am sonntag wieder gibt's
neues video das war's haut rein